Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schön guten Morgen Richard einen guten
Morgen Markus große Aufregung diese
Woche hier weiß ich ob das mitgekriegt
hast wir haben Sendung produziert und
kurz bevor wir anfangen wollten kommt
diese Meldung Absturz eines
privatfliegers auf dem Weg von Moskau
nach St Petersburg und dann bin ich
später helle Aufregung weil auf der
Passagierliste der Name prigosh ihn
auftauchte
Putins Koch und dann überschlugen sich
plötzlich die Ereignisse und die
Meldungen und die Spekulationen vor
allen Dingen
erst war die Rede davon das Flugzeug sei
abgestürzt und ich dachte lass es
aussehen wie ein Unfall man das war die
Meldung auf die wir eigentlich alle
gewartet hatten und deswegen
war mein zweiter Gedanke na ja also man
kann über diesen Tod für den Fall dass
er sich um brigos in den Chef der
wagnergruppe handelt alles mögliche
sagen aber sicher nicht die Formulierung
die berühmte Formulierung plötzlich und
unerwartet ja auf den Tag genau zwei
Monate
mit diesem Arsch richtig zumindestens
nicht aus heiterem Himmel gekommen genau
das das kann man so sagen und dann dann
dachte ich irgendwie was was heißt das
jetzt eigentlich und dann kriegte ich
und das war dann sehr interessant und
das haben wir auch in der Sendung
verwendet eine Nachricht von einem
Mann der sehr nah an selensky dran ist
ein aus dem
Beraterteam der sagte es fällt auf wie
schnell die Bestätigung von offiziellen
Stellen in Russland für diesen Tod kam
weil man Dritter Gedanke war was wenn
das die Ukraine waren was für das jetzt
richtig ist oder irgendein anderer
westlicher Geheimdienstes zum Beispiel
gibt ja so viele Leute die
eine offene Rechnung mit diesem
mariaalen zum Beispiel jemand der so
einem blutigen Handwerk nachgehen das
tut oder getan hat ich meine der hat
unglaublich viele Feinde ja ja auch
genügend Feinde die nicht davor
zurückschrecken im Zweifelsfall so ein
Flugzeug ist das denn jetzt weiß man das
eigentlich abgeschossen oder ist das ist
das überhaupt definitiv oder Nein vom
Himmel gefallen weil ich gelesen aber da
ist mit der ist mir das kann ja auch
irgendwie ein Sprengstoff drin gewesen
sein
also im Moment im Moment tendieren die
Spekulationen eher in Richtung einer
einer
Flugabwehrrakete und ich habe mir
erzählen lassen von Leuten die sich
damit sehr viel besser auskennen dass
das auch relativ leicht zu machen ist
also es ist alles was du brauchst ist es
ist so eine so eine wie so eine
Panzerfaust ne die schon im Afghanistan
Krieg im Einsatz war und dann sagte ich
na gut wo kriegt man den sowas her und
immerhin na ja gegen Geld in Russland
eigentlich überall gar kein Problem und
dann lassen sich relativ leicht die
Koordinaten sozusagen klären also wie
wird dieses Flugzeug fliegen und dann
ist das ähm eine smarte Waffe und dann
holen die die vom Himmel das ist rein
technisch kein Problem und was natürlich
auffällt und das ist etwas
wo ich sagen würde
das geht dann eher in Richtung Russland
und Putin und da wäre ich dann bei Joe
Biden der ja auch sagte es gibt wenig
was in Russland geschieht bei dem nicht
Putin irgendwie dahinter steckt es fällt
auf da passiert das und nur wenige
Minuten später meldet die Taste die
amtliche der russische
Nachrichtenagentur das auf der
Passagierliste dieser Name auftaucht das
ist natürlich ich sag mal man könnte
sagen das ist plump wenn man das System
ein bisschen verfolgt hat in den letzten
Jahren und Jahrzehnten würde ich sagen
das ist so gewollt Moment genau und in
die Richtung ging auch dieser diese
diese ganz kurze Analyse dieses Elements
Beraters der sagte ja gut aber dass der
Silvester morgen in den eigenen
neutraler was der sagt auch selber
abwarten was was die was sozusagen dann
der die oft der offizielle
Untersuchungsberichte ja manchmal
interessieren ob vielleicht also
findet also ich meine es hätte genauso
viele Gründe wie es ist für seine Feinde
gibt ihn zu töten genauso viele Gründe
gibt es für prigoshi zu verschwinden ja
also seine Identität aufzulösen er hat
die Möglichkeiten dafür und es können
auch seine eigenen Leute gewesen sein
die das Flugzeug abgeschossen haben und
tatsächlich war er nicht an Bord ich
meinte das sind ja alles wieder
Spekulationen ja ich weiß nicht ich
wundere mich immer über die Leute die
schon so ziemlich sicher und ziemlich
genau wissen dass es putin war obwohl
sie das nicht wissen können ich finde
einfach man sollte jetzt nicht nicht das
Denken was man gerne denken möchte
sondern ich finde wir sollen erstmal
abwarten bis wirklich in letzter Instanz
geklärt ist falls das überhaupt je
wirklich geklärt wird das ist der Punkt
weil ich finde schon dass man sich dass
man sich da zurückhält in die was
interessantes ist halt diese Dynamik die
das ist ja eigentlich die Frage dahinter
und darüber habe ich mit Rüdiger von
Fritz stimmt ehemaligen deutschen
Botschaftern Moskau gesprochen die dy
ruhig dahinter also dieser Marsch auf
Moskau vor zwei Monaten der hat
erkennbar diesem Regime Angst gemacht
und da war ja kurze Zeit echter
Kontrollverlust ja da man steht einfach
jemand innerhalb des eigenen Landes auf
dem eigenen territor marschiert
keine Gegenwehr und so ne richtig Kadir
auf der der
spielte dann auch noch eine Rolle und so
weiter also zwei Lose Bordkanonen
sozusagen innerhalb des Landes unterwegs
und Putin ist jemand der nichts verzeiht
das haben die letzten 10
Leute verzeihen nicht genau
aber andererseits ich meine ich weiß
dass viele im Westen sich ja gefreut
haben über Smart ich persönlich übrigens
nicht ich hatte riesige Angst das könnte
glücklich ja und ich ich denke ein Prio
ist noch 100 mal durchgeknallter als ein
Putin also ich glaube es ist ja noch
viel viel gefährlicher und schlimmer
gewesen aber auch das ist alles
Spekulation ich denke nur dass das
natürlich auch ein interess daran geben
kann wieder Unruhe nach Russland
reinzubringen indem man die These in die
Welt setzt Putin hat prigoshim
umgebracht ja und deswegen muss er das
auch nicht selber gewesen sein ich frag
mich immer aber ich habe da auch keine
Ahnung von man kann hätte das ja
wahrscheinlich auch anders machen können
also und genau Autounfall oder morgens
im Bett nicht aufgewacht und so weiter
also wenn das tatsächlich so gewesen
sein soll dass man also vor den Augen
der Öffentlichkeit den mit einer Rakete
abgeschossen hat
das wäre auch schon wieder ein
Dilettantismus den ich mir wieder
andererseits kaum noch vorstellen kann
aber man weiß es nicht so geworden
also dieser
Doppelagent ja genau der russische als
der getötet wurde und man dafür also ein
Kampfstoff genommen hat der auf dem ganz
groß das Wort Sowjetunion stand der also
die der KGB benutzt hat und eigentlich
sonst keiner wo man sich ja auch die
Frage gestellt hat die gibt es zwei
Möglichkeiten entweder will das jemand
den Russen in die Schuhe schieben oder
die Russen wollen ein Zeichen setzen
dass sie somit Verrätern umgehen
und am Ende wissen wir es wieder in der
einen Sache noch in der anderen Sache
beides halte ich auch für denkbar ja nur
wie Schock ne war glaube
jeder gesagt hat das ist sozusagen aus
den alten giftschränken des KGB richtig
genau also das Benutzen die anderen
nicht genau und nur staatlicherseits
kann man sowas überhaupt herstellen
richtig genau einfach ankommen ja es ist
es ist es ist
finde ich ohnehin ähm beängstigend wie
sich dieser ganze Krieg wie sich das
alles entwickelt was da für Dinge
passieren ich habe neulich nachts sehr
lange mit mit
telefoniert das waren irgendwie absolute
Situation ja ich sitze zu Hause in
telefonieren mit jemandem der in der
Nähe der der Stadt Mahmut
im Schützengraben ist im Moment war dann
irgendwo in einem Hotel
und wir haben anderthalb Stunden nachts
telefoniert weil ich mal wissen wollte
wie diese Situation da wirklich ist und
ronsheimer ist jemand der seit langer
Zeit diesen Krieg verfolgt auch schon
seit 2014 immer wieder in der ausdrucken
unterwegs war es gibt wenige diese
Situation dort so gut und so genau
kennen Katrin Eugendorf gehört sich auch
dazu und er sagte mir dieser Krieg ist
in einer fürchterlichen Phase 3 km vor
drei Kilometer zurück Erfolgsmeldungen
die in Wahrheit eigentlich nur sagen wir
haben jetzt irgendwie eine freie Fläche
erobert und da haben sie gesagt ja genau
und die und die Kehrseite davon ist und
da kommen jetzt zum Thema Waffen und ich
würde heute gerne mit dir auch über den
Film dieses sommersprechen
Oppenheimer über die ganz fürchterlichen
Waffen aber ganz grundsätzlich über die
Frage was Waffen anrichten können Paul
sagte ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben
so viele junge Männer mit einem Bein
gesehen
[Musik]
genau genau
das und der sagte und er sagte wir
müssen jetzt irgendwann mal ernsthaft
überlegen wie wir damit umgehen wie
lange hält eine Gesellschaft in dem Fall
die ukrainische wie lange halten die das
irgendwelchen Sinn machen
man hätte ja beim Ersten Weltkrieg sagen
müssen im Nachhinein ne da wo man
schlauer ist in dem Moment wo der Krieg
ins Stocken geriet da in Frankreich ja
und die die Schützen Gräben da
ausgehoben worden waren und der
Stellungskrieg begann wo sich dann über
überhaupt nichts mehr großartig
verändert hat in dem Moment hätte
eigentlich Schluss sein müssen weil all
die Menschen die dann noch gestorben
sind ja bis zum Schluss hinter 10.000
und insgesamt 100.000 und so weiter
gestorben
bei einer Sache von der relativ schnell
eigentlich klar sein musste dass ich da
nichts mehr bewegt und die Frage ist
also mit welcher Inbrunst will man einen
Krieg Weiterführen der diesbezüglich gar
keine siegesperspektive ja und und
zwar interessante Gedanken von von Paul
ronsheimer dem Zusammenhang der eine er
sagte entweder und das ist die
Entscheidung von der wir stehen und er
meinte wie ducken uns gerade so also der
der kollektive Westen mit ducken uns da
gerade so weg entweder beliefern wir die
mit den Waffen die sie wirklich brauchen
und helfen Ihnen dann dabei tatsächlich
diese Offensive irgendwann zum Erfolg zu
führen ihr Land zurückzuholen was auch
immer und zwar so nachhaltig dass sie
eine echte Chance haben dass du tun oder
aber wir zwingen sie sozusagen in
irgendeiner Form in Verhandlung also ich
glaube entweder Frage weil das entweder
gibt es nicht
also wir haben geglaubt dass wir wenn
wir die Leopard Panzer liefern dass wir
dann nicht erinnere mich an ein
persönliches Gespräch mit Agnes stark
Zimmermann die also erzählte wie
unglaublich überlegen diese
Waffentechnologie ist und dass man da
relativ schnell bis zur krimit
durchkommt wir haben gesehen du kannst
Vermögen ja fast ihre Art und Weise
irgendwie für vieles perfekt sein aber
das was wir uns als Wunderwaffe
versprochen haben das war es nicht das
wird das sagen die Experten ja auch das
wird auch bei den Kampfflugzeugen so
sein ja und auch mit Hilfe der Taurus
Raketen wird sich dann diesbezüglich
nicht ändern das heißt wir verfügen
nicht über Wunderwaffen die der Ukraine
dazu verhelfen ganz offensichtlich in
kürzester Zeit diesen Krieg zu gewinnen
ich glaube es ist keine entweder oder
Entscheidung ich glaube wir machen uns
immer noch was vor dass wir immer noch
denken wir könnten auf dem alten Weg
weitermachen dadurch dass wir noch mehr
Waffen und noch mehr Waffen und noch
mehr Waffen einsetzen und die
Leidtragenden sind die Soldaten auf
beiden Seiten ja die ohne mit einem Bein
oder Gräber in denen eine Hand ja oder
und was von ich meine immer sich
vorstellen diese diese Geschosse
zerfetzten pulverisieren der Körper
verbrennen die genau also all dieses
unvorstellbare grauen was da passiert
ohne dass wir jetzt sagen können hier
besteht eine ganz realistische
Perspektive den Krieg in diese oder
diese Richtung zu entscheiden
ja sieht und die Frage ist was muss
passieren damit man das einsieht ja auf
beiden Seiten das ist ja also was ist
die Konsequenz daraus wir haben gerade
über Kinder gesprochen werden darüber
gesprochen warum Menschen das tun was
sie tun wenn du er sagte nämlich auch
wenn du die Ukraine fragst wollt ihr das
weiter wollt ihr weiter euer Land
verteidigen wollt ihr eure Kinder
beschützen ja und so große Fragen geht's
ja dann am Ende wollt ihr nicht dass
eure Kinder irgendwo nach Russland
verschleppt werden dass ihr selber
möglicherweise in Lager kommt und so das
sind die Ängste der Menschen dort dann
sagen natürlich
alternative jetzt zu deinen Fragen die
Frage ist was wäre wenn man einen Krieg
mit dem bisherigen Grenzverlauf
provisorisch einfriert das ist das
worüber wir reden wir reden nicht
darüber den den Russen die Ukraine zu
überlassen sondern wir reden ja davon
dass wir sagen wir stellen die
Kampfhandlungen an beiden Seiten der
Front erstmal ein also das ist ja der
Punkt über den hier ernsthaft diskutiert
wird und dann weiß ich genau dass die
Ukraine darauf antworten würden weil das
eine ganz andere Frage als die Fragen
die Du sie formuliert hast aber was mich
interessiert was ich psychologisch so
spannend findet wann ist der Punkt dass
man sich in der Frage ehrlich macht und
nicht denkt ja gute Grund ist weil wenn
ich schnell genug und nicht genug Waffen
geliefert habe müssen halt noch mehr
Waffen und wenn dies nicht tun dann
müssen wir noch mehr Waffen und noch
mehr Waffen also militärische Logik wann
kommt der Punkt wo die Leute die diese
Logik verfechten sagen das gibt nichts
wir müssen einen anderen Weg finden wir
müssen keine riesigen Zugeständnisse
machen sondern alles was wir jetzt
machen müssen ist die Luft aus dem Krieg
rausnehmen und du klar was auch Bitters
in dem zusammen habe ich auch mit mit
Paul ronsheimer letzte Nacht länger
drüber gesprochen er sagte kann es
eigentlich ernsthaft sein dass jetzt
irgendwelche Autokraten und des Boten
dass die ernsthaft jetzt einladen zu
Verhandlungen also
Mohammed bin Salman ausseriert
Saudi-Arabien Erdogan spielt seine Rolle
warum machen wir das nicht Chinesen
machen Vorschläge Afrikaner machen
Vorschläge auch nicht alles lupenreine
Demokratien so also ich kann nur daran
erinnern dass beim letzten Mal gerade
die Franzosen und die deutschen diese
Rolle übernommen haben aber wir stehen
und das ist unsere unseren Politikern
sehr klar zu leben für diese Rolle
offensichtlich nicht zur Verfügung und
es gibt niemand der in diese Lücke
tatsächlich reingehen könnte
und weil das kannst du dir denken für
falsch ich würde Deutschland sehr sehr
gerne in einer Vermittlung sind nicht
als neutraler Vermittler das waren wir
auch bei Minsk nicht sondern einfach um
dieses Grauen und dieses Schlachten
erstmal zu beenden weil das das Beste
was wir tun können
ja es war und trotzdem muss man immer
wieder an dem Punkt erwähnen ich glaube
in der in der Logik von Putin in der
Logik der Russen ist das natürlich ein
ganz ganz anderes Spiel jemand der an
Waffenstillstand anbietet jemand der
sich schwach zeigt jemand der sich
verwundbar zeigt der zu erkennen gibt
dass er nicht mehr kann ist natürlich
jemand bei dem man weitermacht das
verstärkt den Appetit des aggress aus
und mal mit Joachim Gauck zu zu sein ich
kenne Joachim Gaucks Blick auf Russland
ne für den ist das jetzt natürlich noch
der das alte sowjetische Erbe was er da
sieht und er ist ein glühender
Antikommunist und daher kommt dann auch
seine Haltung es kann sein dass er Recht
hat es kann auch sein dass er nicht
recht hat es kann auch sein dass die
russische Bevölkerung hat viel viel
Krieg müde ist als wir glauben
das weiß ich alles nicht also ich finde
bevor man das probiert hat sollte man
solche Spekulationen nicht vorstellen
weil solange wir nicht bereit sind doch
nur ein Schritt zu gehen
das ganze weiterhin so weitergehen dann
wird das Schlachten und morden und so
weiter weitergehen und dann werden am
Ende ohne dass ich am Ende vielleicht
der Frontverlauf noch maßgeblich
verändert hat noch 50.000 100.000
vielleicht noch mehr Menschen gestorben
sein völlig sinnlos wenn wir darüber
reden ich habe dieser Tage was
interessantes gelesen auch über den
Ukraine Krieg KI spielt eine immer
größere Rolle auch in diesem
Kriegerin eine Rolle das ist die Firma
unter anderem von von Peter Thiel die
erstaunlich viele Dinge macht und diese
diese KI hilft sozusagen Ziele zu
identifizieren mit Hilfe von
Satellitenbildern alle möglichen KI
spielt eine riesige Rolle auch im
Bereich der militärischen Logistik und
so weiter bisher konnte man ungefähr 24
Ziele pro Tag finden mit Hilfe dieser
Software und KI sind es mittlerweile
mehrere hundert die du markierst und
dann ganz langsam
auf die Art und Weise erkannt und
wirklich wie bei tinder ganz einfache
Software wisch und weg so war auch die
Überschrift irgendwie alles sehr sehr
guten Stückes dass ich dazu bei den
Kollegen der Süddeutschen gelesen habe
und ich habe in dem Zusammenhang dieser
Tage ein völlig neues Wort kennengelernt
hast das schon mal gehört kill chain
ich kann dir nur dieser chain die
Lieferketten rund um Corona aber die die
die tötungskette ja da wird sozusagen
darüber geredet wie sich die kill chain
verändert ja also der Ablauf einer
Attacke aufspüren eines Ziels und dann
Zerstörung eines Ziels und damit meinen
wir nicht irgendein ein abstraktes Ziel
damit meinen wir im Zweifel Fahrzeuge
Panzer in den am Ende auch immer wieder
Menschen sitzen und so weiter
Computerspiele an und soll sich
Nachkomme
die grauigkeit des Krieges ja wird auf
diese Art und Weise verschleiert
früher Euphemismen ja dass man also
irgend so ein heroischen Zuckerguss
darüber gegossen hat sondern heute nimmt
man einfach so alberne Worte ja aus dem
Alltag oder aus der Spielewelt ja genau
und gruselige Dinge zu tarnen genau und
und das entscheidende dabei und da muss
ich immer denken an diesen einen Drohnen
Piloten der im fernen Amerika ich glaube
in New Mexiko und um Container saß und
im Irak Menschen in die Luft gejagt hat
du verschleierst die Verantwortung die
Verantwortlichkeit ne die die
Zuständigkeiten werden komplett
verschleiert ich habe den damals gefragt
weiß ich noch er sagt ich kann da rein
und ich drücke auf diesen Knopf und alle
stehen um mich herum und und wir ziehen
runter auf zehn und kurz bevor der weiße
Blitz kommt läuft plötzlich ein Kind aus
diesem Haus und wir pulverisieren dieses
gesamte Haus und natürlich auch dieses
arme Kind weil wir den Verdacht hatten
da sitzt an al-Qaida
Hochzeitsgesellschaft glaube ich sogar
es war ein Haus eine Funkzelle und ein
al-Qaida Kommandeur war dort offenbar
drin und alles was dort in der Nähe war
flog natürlich mit in die Luft und
dieser Mann war traumatisiert davon weil
er sagte ich habe mich umgedreht und
sagte zu dem zu dem zuständigen hinter
mir du wir haben gerade ein Kind
umgebracht und der guckt ihn an und sagt
das war ein Hund ja genau gesagt
erinnere mich und deshalb wir sind uns
eigentlich das war ein Hund und ihm
Protokoll stand später es war ein Hund
ja oder oder wenn du hörst z.B das
Drohnen die dann das Geschehen mit
beobachten ja die nur dafür da sind das
zu protokollieren von der entsprechenden
Geheimdienste die dann entscheiden
Moment werden die Kameras weggeschwenkt
damit keiner weiß was da unten wirklich
passiert ist also solche Dinge dienen
dazu sozusagen die Verantwortlichkeiten
zu verschleiern dann kann man immer
sagen wir waren es nicht ich weiß nicht
nein da ist eine Entlastung wieder
stattfindet und gerade in der Ukraine
dieser
frage mich mal damit beschäftigt das ist
ein Labor ein echtes Labor mittlerweile
auch für künstliche Intelligenz mir
sagte jemand vor wenigen Tagen weißt du
was das wichtigste ist im Moment für die
Ukraine das aller aller Wichtigste sind
nicht Waffensysteme sind nicht neuer
Raketen sind nicht Panzer sind nicht
Jagdbomber sind nicht Panzerhaubitzen
das allerwichtigste ist Darling von Elon
Musk das Kommunikationsnetz und die die
Leute im Hintergrund ärgern sich zu Tode
dass sie Elon Musk sehr sehr viel Geld
dafür bezahlen müssen dass er dort an
Kommunikationssystem aufrecht erhält das
sozusagen etwas ist von dem das Pentagon
selber weiß davon sind wir zehn Jahre
entfernt ohne starlink hätten die
Ukraine keine Chance
Ziele auszumachen zu kommunizieren und
so weiter und es gibt einen Aspekt den
ich sehr interessant fand sauer war das
ja der sich wirklich damit auskennt der
sagte
es gab die Berichte dass Elon Musk mit
Putin telefoniert hat und Putin soll ihn
davon überzeugt haben war dieser Tage
auch zu lesen dass die Creme ohnehin
historisch russisches Gebiet sei was
dazu führte dass Elon Musk starlink im
Bereich Krim auch was die Brücken und so
weiter angeht abgeschaltet hat die die
Ukraine sind dort quasi blind das
entscheidet ein Milliardär im fernen
Kalifornien der auf diese Art und Weise
genau darf diese Art und Weise mit in
diesen Krieg eingreift die Ukraine sind
im Bereich der Krim weitestgehend blind
nachrichtendienstlich und abhängig von
Elon Musk dass das das sind so Dinge
sind das gruselige an all denen man kann
diese Systeme und jetzt an dem was sie
jetzt da über über Maske erzählt dieser
Krieg ist ja nicht nur ein einziges
großes grauen was nicht endet das ist
auch gleichzeitig eine Messe
ja es ist eine die größte Waffenmesse
der Welt hier kann man dann genau
demonstrieren und vorführen welche
Waffen können was und so weiter und die
Folge dieses Krieges sind dann
gigantische Rüstungsaufträge weil es an
der parallele natürlich gibt zum Film
der Stunde dem Film überhaupt Oppenheim
ja dem Vater der Atombombe sozusagen ein
Mann der ja im Grunde mit seiner
Erfindung das war der Clou an der
Geschichte mit der Erfindung der
Atombombe Kriege eigentlich unmöglich
machen wollte der ja geglaubt hat wenn
wir das Ding einmal ausprobieren dann
werden die Leute sich so erschrecken und
so verstört sein darüber dass sie danach
für immer sowohl den Abwurf von
Atombomben als auch Kriege an sich
bleiben lassen ne ähnliche Diskussion
hast du jetzt auch beim Thema KI die wo
auch führende Leute immer wieder sagen
Oldman und andere der der der der Mann
der GPT gegründet hat z.B der sagt wir
wir haben da ein Werkzeug in der Hand
von dem man mal schauen muss was damit
wirklich macht andere die sagen lass uns
da mal an Moratorium verhängen eine
Pause lass uns mal überlegen was die
Regeln sind für den Einsatz von KI und
damit auch für den Einsatz von KI bei
Waffensystemen die immer intelligenter
könnte man positiv sagen aber auch
perfider werden und genau das waren doch
die Diskussion rund um den Bau dieser
Atombombe ja also die die
Gemeinsamkeiten sind da
und was was mich
beschäftigt ist ich habe ja ein Buch
über künstliche Intelligenz geschrieben
und meine These darin war ja künstliche
Intelligenz darf keine Entscheidung über
menschliches Leben und menschliche Leben
Schicksale Fällen genau das ist die rote
Linie so und damit war natürlich für
mich auch klar keine Verwendung von KI
in militärischen Bereich
und das war gleichzeitig die Meinung
sehr sehr vieler Wissenschaftler weil es
gibt ganz viele ethische
Selbstverpflichtungen und Kartas die
aufgesetzt worden sind wo eben auch
Wissenschaftler Informatik arbeiten und
so weiter sagen das ist auch für uns die
Grenze ja das wollen wir nicht keine
Killer Roboter so hieß die Diskussion
damals
und jetzt seit dem Ukraine Krieg ist
alles anders ja jetzt ist das Argument
wenn wir nicht mit künstlicher
Intelligenz alles das machen was wir
militärisch machen können dann machen es
die anderen und jetzt gibt's den
wechselseitiges hochrüsten jetzt kommen
wir überhaupt nicht mehr dran vorbei und
jetzt ist es die Frage nicht nur
aufklärungs- und Logistiksysteme zu
haben sondern eben auch tötungssysteme
also nicht nur aufführen sondern gleich
auch sofort die Drohne da rein und so
weiter dass man das also alles sozusagen
dass man damit eine super Wasser
entwickelt wie man ihn nicht atomaren
kriegen ähm bestmöglich einsetzen kann
und das ist natürlich klar was hier
passiert dann würde auf der Gegenseite
würde das auch eingesetzt soweit da ist
oder was man kann oder das ist auch
alles eine Frage der Zeit die Russen
waren ja auch bei der Atombombe ein paar
Jahre hinterher konnten das dann aber
auch das gleiche würde auch hier
passieren ja genau eigentlich ein
Wettrüsten genau aber es ist sehr
bezeichnend als die Europäische Union
vor einem halben Jahr ihre Leitlinien
zur KI veröffentlicht hat ja die auch so
auch die Grundlage für
Gesetzgebungsverfahren sein sondern
haben Sie von Anfang an gesagt wir
nehmen alles Militärische raus das heißt
also es ist erlaubt
wir machen keinerlei Begrenzung also wir
denken darüber nach was darf KI in der
Medizin ja was kann man mit kaine
Datenverarbeitung machen was ist mit KI
in Autos und so weiter ja da dürfen die
Entscheidung überleben und Tod Fällen
und sie haben gesagt aber über
militärisches diskutieren wir nicht das
Verantwortung auch die Europäische
Kommission hat gesagt dieses Thema was
nehmen wir uns nicht an genau das findet
aber stark das findet statt sondern da
wird immer Augenblick massiv etwas
gemacht weil es keinen
gesellschaftlichen Gegendruck gibt weil
jeder sagt wir brauchen das doch sonst
machen ist die anderen und da sind wir
in der gleichen Logik drin die damals
zur Entwicklung der Atombombe geführt
hat nein ich meine die Atombombe wurde
ja dass man hätten Projekt wurde ja
gemacht weil man wusste dass die die
Nazis an Atomwaffen arbeiten und deshalb
ging darum dass man schneller ist für
den Fall der Fälle das war die erste
Motivation
nicht so weit weil die zweite Motivation
bestand darin ähm die die die neue
Führungsrolle die die USA durch Musik im
Zweiten Weltkrieg bekommen hatten
auszubauen und die führende militärische
Weltmacht überhaupt zu werden und der
größte Konkurrent in dem Moment war ja
nicht mehr Japan das war ja noch eine
Frage der Zeit bis Japan kapitulierte
sondern der große Konkurrenz war die
Sowjetunion also Hiroshima ist letztlich
aus der Sicht der Amerikaner nicht gegen
Japaner abgeworfen worden sondern gegen
die Sonne
wir mal noch mal vor Augen führst was
damals passiert ist das
little boy ne hieß glaube
vier Tonnen schwere Atombombe
und immer die die Eckdaten also wenn man
sich das mal vorstellt 2:45 Uhr morgens
startet dieses Flugzeug 13 Mann
Besatzung von einer kleinen Insel und um
8:15 Uhr und genau 17 Sekunden werfen
Sie diese Bombe aus fast 10000 Metern
Höhe ab und den 580 m Höhe also knapp
über dem Boden detoniert dieses Ding
Lidl Boy über der Innenstadt von
Hiroshima und den weniger als einer
einzigen Minute macht diese Druckwelle
praktisch die gesamte Innenstadt dem
Erdboden gleich von 76.000 Häusern
werden praktisch 70.000 zerstört oder
bestätigt 80.000 Menschen sterben auf
der Stelle und tausende weitere in der
Folge an radioaktiver Verstrahlung
und wenige Tage später geht dann der
Kaiser das Ende des Krieges bekannt zu
einem unvorstellbar hohen Preis was man
vielleicht noch dazu erzählen soll weil
es wird selten dazu erzählt die
Todeszahlen die hier genannt werden
werden weit übertroffen von den
Todeszahlen der konventionellen
Bombardements der Amerikaner auf Tokio
richtig also wir haben ja auch in
jüngster Zeit furchtbarer Moos erlebt ne
man denke an Aleppo man denke an Mossul
wo ihr auch halbe Städte millionenstätte
dem Erdboden gleich gemacht sind durch
unausgesetzte luftausgriffe also der
Amerikaner und der Russen die größten
Luftangriffe in der Geschichte der
Menschheit waren die Bombardierungen der
Amerikaner von Tokio wo 200.000 Menschen
gestorben sind durch konventionelle
Bombe muss also noch vor dem Einsatz der
Atombombe also das was da in Japan
passiert ist das ist ja sozusagen das
eine plus das andere dann noch drauf und
der der es gibt viele Diskussionen
darüber und und Fachbücher über die
Frage wie militärischen notwendig
der Einsatz der der Atombomben gewesen
ist und man muss sagen es ist relativ
schwer die These aufrecht zu erhalten
dass das notwendig gewesen ist aus
militärischen Grund also
ein paar Wochen später
amerikanischen Bevölkerung weil ich habe
mit einem Menschen mal lange gesprochen
ich habe mal bei dem gewohnt in Amerika
der mein Pazifikkrieg eingesetzt der war
auf den Philippinen und den haben die
gesagt sie müssten sich vorbereiten für
die Invasion von Japan und da gab es in
den Medien so Hochrechnung wie viel
100.000 GIS sterben würden bei dem
Versuch ganz Japan zu erobern und dann
hat man gesagt dadurch dass wir die
Atombombe abgeworfen haben haben wir
sozusagen das Leben von 100.000
Amerikanern gerettet so hat man das
gegengerechnet aber die Faktor hätte ist
eine solche Invasion gar nicht mehr
bedarf also das war der Krieg war
entschieden also das kann man das kann
man sich nicht schön rechnen dass diese
dass diese Abwurf militärisch notwendig
gewesen wäre
gibt gibt ja sozusagen die überwiegende
Mehrheit ne bei der Historikern ist ja
mittlerweile ist die sagen dieser
Atombombe hat sicher nicht zum Ende des
Krieges geführt andere sagen doch eine
Woche verkürzt oder so aber das war
nicht der Sinn des Lebens genau trotzdem
interessante
Aussage eines ethikprofessors von der TU
München Marcello jenker der sagt wenn
man davon ausgeht dass die Atombombe
zwar viele Menschen getötet hat aber
wahrscheinlich noch mehr Menschen
gerettet dann kann man die Erfindung der
Atombombe 45 als moralisch
gerechtfertigt haben aber er sagt aber
auch gleichzeitig bedeutet nicht ne dass
sie heute noch angemessen wäre aber er
sagt er sagt doch richtigerweise ja also
nicht der Abwurf der Atombombe genau ja
also die Atomtest sie sprachen ja auch
nur deutlich Sprache
also man hätte man hätte ja auch also
Edward Teller der der also einer einer
der der härtesten Krieger überhaupt der
dann hinter der Wasserstoff rumgesteckte
und der dann die von Oppenheim
weitergeführt hat der hat im Nachhinein
sich die Sache schön getrunken indem er
gesagt hat er wäre ja eigentlich immer
der Ansicht gewesen man hätte nicht die
Atombomben abwerfen sollen sondern hätte
demonstrieren sollen also man hätte
sozusagen die beiden in einem Atombomben
Versuch abwerfen sollen hätte man ja
auch die japanische Delegation in
einladen können oder so mal zu zeigen
nach dem Motto wenn ihr jetzt nicht
spurt dann passiert das die Geschichte
ist gelogen stimmt alles nicht und so
weiter aber die richtige Worte daran ist
man hätte tatsächlich dafür nicht die
Menschen alle umbringen müssen also dass
die Atombombe und das dazu geführt hat
oder das Gleichgewicht langfristig was
ja noch gar nicht erreicht was muss man
auch noch mal sagen ne also hätte es
nicht entsprechend der Spionage gegeben
durch Fuchs und andere und so weiter die
den äh den den so wie jetzt damals die
die Pläne und und und alles mögliche da
verraten hätten dann hättest du
vielleicht lange Sicht wahrscheinlich in
amerikanische hiergemonie als at
Ohnmacht gegeben und was dann am Ende so
gruselig das ist zu dem Gleichgewicht
geführt hat war die Tatsache dass beide
Seiten darüber vorfinden was was man
einmal vielleicht mal kurz einsortieren
muss ich wusste das auch in den Details
alles nicht ein bisschen mich nicht
damit man ein bisschen beschäftigt habe
ich habe ja damals einen richtigen
Wettlauf ne zwischen man wusste die
Nazis entwickeln diese Bomben ja es war
klar durch Forschungen unter anderem von
des Ehepaars Curie Marie Curie die erste
Frau überhaupt in Nobelpreis in Physik
bekommen und in Chemie und den Chemie
dann später auch noch irgendwie auch
interessant damals
1911 gebeten wurde der Verleihung ist
hier nie Nobelpreises fern zu bleiben
weil sie eine Affäre mit einem
verheirateten französischen
Wissenschaftler hatte und sie war die
böse Frau natürlich die der Armen
anderen Frau der Armen Französisch ihren
Mann weggenommen hat also der Mann hatte
damit nichts zu tun es war es war
sozusagen die böse Frau und sie ist dann
trotzdem hingegangen und hat sich diesen
Nobelpreis rausgeholt das fand für die
sehr interessant die aber die
entscheidende Forschung gemacht hat zu
Polonium und Radium und so weiter
radioaktivitäten wurde dann durch später
gestorben ist ja weil sie bei diesen
Experimenten fürchterlich verstrahlt
worden ist und keine eigentlich wusste
was da wirklich passiert und dann glaube
1934 dann sehr junge mit 60 oder so
verstorben ist aber die dieser dieser
dieser Wettlauf es war klar die Nazis
versuchen das und die Amerikaner wussten
die machen das wir müssen das auch
machen und dann setzen die diese Logik
auf ne hier ist ja völlig genau dieses
Manhattan Project auf am Ende glaube ich
kostet das 2 Milliarden in New Mexico in
in Alamos stehen diese diese diese
Anlagen und
Oppenheimer sehr junger talentierter
Wissenschaftler damals glaube ich gerade
mal 38 Jahre also noch keine 40 Jahre
gilt als talentiert ist da Physiker der
USA und der führt dieses Team von 3000
Mann an und die machen diese Tests und
irgendwann gelingt das und dann gibt es
einen Punkt der auch in dem Film eine
Rolle spielt und da kriegst du Gänsehaut
wenn du das siehst kein Physiker hatte
keine Ahnung von sowas der wird gefragt
kann es sein dass wir bis dahin war das
alles graue Theorie und nur Papier kann
es sein dass wir die Atmosphäre in Brand
stecken wenn wir diese Atombombe zünden
also heißt kann es in die Atmosphäre
Bestätigung auch aus Gasen kann es sein
dass wir diese ganzen Moleküle die da
sind und so weiter dazu bringen eine
Kettenreaktion auszulösen und plötzlich
brennt der gesamte Erdball und er sagt
die Wahrscheinlichkeit geht gegen Null
und der verantwortliche sagt ich hätte
gerne wenn sie wirklich bei Null wäre
sagt das kann ich dir aber nicht
versprechen ich meine mit solchen Dingen
hat man da experimentiert das musst du
die mal klar machen und wenn du das
liest und siehst und hörst dann
verstehst du wir wissen bis heute viel
zu wenig eigentlich über das was
nukleare Bedrohung wirklich ist ja
wahrscheinlich ja und ich erinnere mich
daran in friedensbewegungszeiten dass es
immer hieß die modernen Atomwaffen haben
die Hundertfache tausendfache so und so
vielfache Sprengkraft der Hiroshima
Bombe genau
auf die Atombombe so einen Loch
draufsetzen konnte was er noch mal eine
ganz andere Dimension und so weiter hat
das also das also klar war
dass das ein solcher Krieg tatsächlich
auf immer menschliches Leben auf der
Erde unmöglich machen würde nein
hantierte man ja plötzlich mit ganz
anderen Kategorien ich meine Krieger
wieder ein Mittel der Realpolitik ja
also bevor es Atomwaffen gab und man
hatte gedacht dass es zumindest in
Europa nie wieder dazu kommen würde
heute sehen wir ja dass es wieder so ist
also heute ist es ja ganz merkwürdig wir
haben ja immer gedacht
konventionelle Kriege können im
Atomzeitalter zwischen den Großmächten
nicht stattfinden und jetzt haben wir
quasi ein indirekten Krieg zwischen
Großmächten der stattfindet trotz der
Atomwaffen indem man quasi so ein
bisschen so tut als würden die nicht
mitspielen
die ich mir vor wenigen Jahren noch
überhaupt nicht hätte ausmalen können
und wir können auch nach wie vor
sozusagen das Risiko nicht kalkulieren
je nachdem wie sich der Krieg entwickelt
also solange er sich nicht entwickelt
wie im Augenblick ist das Risiko eines
Atomkrieges sehr gering
aber wenn dieser Krieg die Dynamik
bekäme die sich viele im Westen wünschen
dass also die Ukraine im großen Stil
Territorium zurückerobert und bis auf
die Krim kommt dann wird ja im gleichen
Ausmaß wieder der Atomkrieg ernst zu
nehmen wahrscheinlich ich sage nicht
dass er wahrscheinlicher ist als dass er
nicht passiert aber dann müssen wir ganz
ernsthaft mit einbeziehen dass die
Russen vielleicht eine Atombombe auf
Kiew werfen oder andere grausige Dinge
geschehen ja interessant ist ja das dass
dieser Film
Oppenheim der Dauer 3 Stunden ist dann
endloser Film ich habe vernichtende
Kritiken darüber gelesen ich habe
himmlische Kritiken darüber gelesen aber
Fakt ist er trifft offenbar einen nervt
fast eine Milliarde Dollar mittlerweile
ein Spielergebnis nur Barbie war noch
deutlich erfolgreich
zu vergleichen ja es gibt sozusagen es
gibt einen einen einen einen sozusagen
Berührungspunkte das ist ganz
interessant ja du hast also Oppenheimer
und du hast Barbie im Kino ja der Bikini
genau
und seinen Namen genau diesem Südsee
Atoll auf dem ihr ab den 50ern die noch
weit größere Wasserstoffbombe getestet
worden ist übrigens
davon nie wieder erholt hat ja deswegen
waren wir doch in den 90ern dann auch so
gegen diese französischen
Atomuhr ja ich kann mich auch erinnern
da gab es meinen mutigen Jugend
Journalisten der hat ein Lied darüber
gemacht und damit seinen Job verloren
Südtiroler so gut aus
okay also Reinhold Messner gemacht
Generation
[Gelächter]
das war der Grund warum wir damals die
diesen diesen Song zusammengeschraubt
haben weil wir weil wir das alle nicht
gut fanden Fax schirak warte genau
damals der Briesen Ärger dafür gekriegt
weil es so weil es hieß das ist erfüllt
den Tatbestand und das auch worum es
dann später bei Jan Böhmermann gehen
Beleidigung eines ausländischen
Staatsoberhaupt ist aber der Vorteil war
das nicht mitgekriegt hat anders als
Erdogan oder oder
Nein wurde ich nicht wir haben aber vor
dem französischen Konsulat gestanden und
dort gerappt dass das haben wir gemacht
da gibt's glaube ich noch so ein paar
verwackelte Aufnahmen irgendwo bei
Youtube das ist ihre Geschichte
rekrutiert für die Fremdenlegion ja ja
das das war halt irgendwie war uns das
ein Anliegen und wir fanden das
irgendwie nicht gut wir haben das
gespürt und ich glaube das ist auch das
Thema diesem Sommer deswegen gehen so
viele Leute in dieses in diesem in
diesen Film weil sie spüren dass da
etwas das ist von dem wir nicht
ansatzweise verstehen was es wirklich
bedeutet und das interessant ist ja auch
das Filme tatsächlich etwas auslösen
können erinnerst du dich an den Film war
Games oh ja hast du denn gesehen mal den
habe ich gesehen ja genau das war es war
dann da geht sozusagen darum das Hacker
die abschusssysteme für Raketen hacken
und es kommt beinahe zum dritten
Weltkrieg und diesen Film sieht Ronald
Reagan damals US-Präsident 83 und fängt
an sozusagen
den Auftrag zu geben man möge sich ein
bisschen mehr um Sicherheit vor Hackern
kümmern wenn es um um solche Waffen und
Systeme geht und dem gleichen Jahres
sehr interessant kann man dann auch the
day after natürlich Jason Robert
ultimativen Lieblingsschauspieler und
ein wahnsinns Film ne der ja eigentlich
harmlosen Film also wenn man sich
überlegt dass die Leute da das war so
wie ein bisschen war das so gedreht so
wie es gab ja vorhin 70 an diese
Katastrophenfilme er Leben und so ne
also wie viele da alle so ein Atomkrieg
überleben unter so rumlaufen und so also
das war ja nicht der Sinn der Übung aber
er sollte zu einem zumindestens mal also
weil das war ja dann Atombombe ist
gezündet und so weiter und die Frage ist
so wie lebt sich danach ja also die
Geschichte war sozusagen da wird eine
fiktiv natürlich ne an der Atombombe
gezündet und beschreibt dann das elende
Leben im vollkommen verwüsteten kensers
nach einem nuklear kriegt das das ist
der Ort dieses Films der dann den
Hardliner Regen dazu bringt mit
Gorbatschow abrüstungsgespräche zu
führen also ne also man muss jetzt Filme
drehen nimmt und Staatschefs einladen
die sich gemeinsam anzugucken ja
möglicherweise ja und interessant auch
87 weigert sich dann Gorbatschow bei
einem Besuch im Weißen Haus genau dem
Mann über den du gerade gesprochen hast
Edward Teller ja der die
Wasserstoffbombe erfunden hat auch nur
die Hand zu geben aber der hätte sie
auch gern
aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen für
richtig gehalten jetzt passiert
folgendes die Bösen sind weg na also
Nazi Deutschland ist besiegt genau und
nicht die Nazis haben die Atomwaffen
eingesetzt sondern die Amerikaner haben
die Atomwaffen eingesetzt die er gebaut
hat
das hat was mit ihm gemacht
das hat enorm was mit ihm gemacht wird
diese Waffen sind nicht nur das
moralisch gute sondern sie sind auch
einfach ein Mittel der macht ja und wer
die Macht hat der gebraucht sie
und da als dann jetzt sozusagen noch
einen draufsetzen was Wasserstoffbombe
und so weiter was der Teller dann
gemacht hat und Oppenheimer sich
geweigert hat zu machen da war so dieser
Punkt erreicht wo er in dieser Logik
nicht mehr mitspielen wollte mit mit mit
Konsequenzen für ihn ne mit starken
Konsequenzen er ist dann so in kleinen
Schritten immer weiter runter gedisst
worden und er ist ja schließlich sogar
verhört worden er musste sich vor
ausschossen und so weiter rechtfertigen
weil er kommunistische Freunde gehabt
hat vor langer langer Zeit und er wurde
auf einmal getragen
der kommunistische Jude ja und nicht
jeder der amerikanische Patriot ja weil
er nicht mehr eins zu eins am Zügel lief
sondern weil er Gewissensbisse hat hatte
weil er ein ambivalentes Verhältnis hat
er hat ja nicht gesagt ich habe den
Fehler ist ja 100 gemacht weil er gesagt
hat damals war das richtig miteinander
es geht im Moment der dachte sich mein
Gott wenn ich derjenige bin der
maßgeblich dazu beigetragen hat am Ende
die Menschheit auszulöschen dann machst
doch falsch obwohl es in dem Moment
richtig im Kontext richtig waren genau
Gemüse absolut absolut und das finde ich
also diese inneren Kämpfe und dann auch
diese
fürchterliche muss man ja sagen
US-amerikanische Gesellschaft der 50er
Jahre also mit casi wenn jeder der auch
nur ein ganz bisschen von abwich und und
nicht ganz so amerikanisch patriotisch
war und auch nur Skrupel äußerte gleich
als Kommunist in unsiert wurde ja das
ist halt der Punkt ne die die
nuklearstaaten haben genau die Welt
geschaffen die Wissenschaftler wie
Oppenheimer gefürchtet haben und es gibt
ja auch den den den Beleg dafür dass
Truman der Präsident hat ihn dann
irgendwann als Heulsuse verunglilien
furchtbar sagte er ist ständig nicht so
an und das führt natürlich direkt zur
Frage also der Präsidenten der letztlich
dem Befehl dazu gegeben hat die ähm
hirosaki zu zünden ja Wahnsinn überlegt
mal was für eine Konsequenz Japan bis
heute traumatisiert davon ne in in Japan
ist der Film auch also höchst umstritten
und ähm bitte also das kollektives
Trauma wenn du wenn du in Japan bist mit
den Leuten darüber sprichst bis heute
sein absolut kollektives Trauma und dann
kriegt man mal so eine Idee davon was
solche Kriegsverbrechen und nichts
anderes ist es
was die was die mit mit einem Land
machen und das geht über Generationen
pflanzt sich das zu sagen wie so eine
Schockwelle immer weiter fort was zur
Frage führt Richard noch mal
abschließend
wo verläuft die die moralisch-ethische
Linie ich meine Menschen wie Marie Curry
Künstler sagen die haben damit geforscht
wir haben festgestellt da gibt es
Material das strahlt so und dann wird
das plötzlich auf diese Art und Weise
missbraucht und ich möglicherweise war
die noch klar schon zu der Zeit dass man
damit auch Dinge anstellen kann die ganz
fürchterlich sind auf der anderen Seite
haben sie es eingesetzt z.B Radium
eingesetzt um um Röntgenaufnahmen zu
machen also wir haben einen unglaublich
großen Nutzen daraus gezogen haben sogar
sie und ihr Mann Pierre Curie haben
darauf verzichtet ihre Entdeckungen und
Erfindungen rund um Radium zum Patent
anzumelden Unterschied zur heutigen Zeit
also das ist Leute gibt die sie sofort
überlegt haben kann man das für
irgendwelche Zwecke nutzen genau das
kann ich mir vorstellen aber der größte
Unterschied ist das Forschung anders
funktioniert hätte also die Currys
brauchten für ihre Forschung ja keine
fantasillären die braucht man aber heute
wenn man in diese entsprechenden
Forschung KI und so weiter macht und
dahinter stehen Geldgeber Investoren aus
aller Welt Fonds ja der norwegische ÖV
der saudische Staatsform wäre auch immer
im Silicon Valley gerade investiert
Pensionskassen Rentenfonds und so weiter
amerikanische und die machen das ja
alles wichtig nur aus dem einen und
einzigen Grund damit sich das am Ende
finanziell rechnet nicht ohne Menschheit
weiterzubringen und deswegen ist das
logisch so von der Welt dass man
versucht alles was man erfunden oder
gefunden hat sich unter Nagel zu reißen
und patentieren zu lassen weil einfach
Forschung anders funktioniert jedenfalls
auf dieser Ebene es gibt andere
Forschung Leute die
seltene Käfer erforschen da steht dann
keinen Milliarden in Kapital dahinter
und die können dann auch auf alles
Mögliche verzichten die freuen sich dann
wenn ihr Name hinter den Käse kommt aber
hier bei diesen Sachen hier wie bei der
künstlichen Intelligenz das ist ja fast
alles was da gemacht wird die Staaten
spielen ja eine winderwertige Rolle
sondern das ist alles gigantisches
globales Kapital was das vorantreibt und
deswegen wollen die natürlich das liegt
in der Logik des Systems auch dass das
Kapital sich verzinst
siehe biontech zum Beispiel ja
darum ging ja also können die
afrikanischen Länder diese Impfstoffe
bekommen ja wir müssen hier noch nur
erzählen wie es funktioniert dann können
Sie es selber machen und dann hört
natürlich dann wird er die Helfer der
Menschheit dann verändern sich dann über
Nacht relativ schnell das liegt aber
nicht daran dass da irgendwie in
einzelne Personen Entscheidung trifft
sondern auch bei onte ist ja mit Risiko
Kapital ausgestattet worden und auch
dahinter stehen ja Investoren
aber ganz grundsätzlich noch mal der
ethischer Aspekt Richard
zitiere mal robert Oppenheimer es ist
eine scharfsinnige und notwendige
Wahrheit dass die tiefgründigen Fakten
in der Wissenschaft nicht gefunden
werden weil sie nützlich sind sie werden
nur gefunden weil man sich finden konnte
und Marie Curie über die wird schon so
viel gesprochen haben ein Gelehrter in
seinem Laboratorium ist nicht mein
Techniker er steht auch vor der
Naturgesetzen wie ein Kind vor der
Märchenwelt
und dann andere interessanter Satz
kein Wissenschaftler forscht völlig
unbeeinträchtigt von seiner
Weltanschauung und auch unten und auch
nicht unberührt von der Gesellschaft in
der erlebt von wem ist der Satz
ich habe so ein ganz miesen Verdacht von
dir so langhaariger Penner genau ja
interessanter Gedanke also in dem Moment
wo du dich entscheidest also eine
bestimmte Forschung zu machen da
reinzugehen geht eine Frage hast die du
beantwortet haben möchtest den
Geisteswissenschaften in
Naturwissenschaften einen bestimmten
Dingen arbeitest dann ist ja immer schon
eine Vorauswahl getroffen ja warum du
das willst Du damit anfangen kann die
Frage ist darf man das richtig es gibt
keine völlig Wert und zweckfreie
Forschung außer vielleicht bei den
vorhin genannten Käfern also es gibt so
einige Bereiche auch in der Archäologie
zum Beispiel ne würde man sagen also
wenn sich jemand da jetzt für dorische
turnscherben interessiert oder so dass
man sagen kann das ist jetzt völlig frei
von allem und so aber der allergrößte
Teil der Forschung über die wir reden
die dann auch nachher die die
Menschheitsgeschichte verändert diese
diese Forschung erfolgt nichts Weg frei
aber darf man das alles riechen darf man
das darf man erforschen darf man
grundsätzlich schon also alles andere
Frage ja gut jetzt stellst du so fragen
also
hingehen und Chimären züchten zum
Beispiel Chimären unter anderem
menschlichen geben Material also
Schimpansen und Menschen ineinander
verklonen um daraus irgendwelche
Produkte her zu herzustellen so also
solche Fragen einmal kurz erklären weil
du bist Stativ drin in dem Thema ich
wusste das nicht du initiierst sozusagen
spritzt menschliche Stammzellen in sehr
junge oder früher Affen Embryos ja und
beobachtest was dann passiert ja und
stellst fest dass du damit natürlich
erfolgreicher bist als wenn du das mit
mit Ratten machst wie man das bisher
gemacht hat oder mit Mäusen machst mir
ist diese ganze Forschung und ich habe
das begleitet seit Mitte der 90er Jahre
am Anfang journalistisch begleitet
und auch viel darüber geschrieben diese
ganze Stammzellforschung im regionale
Stammzellforschung ist mir persönlich
hochgradig suspekt nicht aus religiösen
Gründen das war ansonsten die stärksten
Gegner sondern weil ich auch im
Zweifelsfall immer denke das braucht es
nicht für das Gott sei Dank nicht also
wir haben in dem Bereich also der der
Reiz ist eine embryonale Stammzelle ist
um die potent genau so Neuschnee ja da
kannst du alles aus Formen genau der
Nachteil ist aber das so entstehendes
Zellgewebe fast immer von demjenigen dem
das implementiert wird oder in der das
transplantiert wird dass derjenige das
häufig abstößt es ist Fremdgewebe das
kann zwar alles aber es ist fremd
gewesen
sind ja Zellen die sozusagen die sind
quasi noch wie soll man sagen die und
die können alles werden
daraus kann eine Lunge werden daraus
keine Leber werden daraus kann
Herzmuskel werden kann alles Mögliche
rausnehmen unterscheiden zwischen den
Körper eigenen Stammzellen also
ist es ja auch Stammzellen zum Beispiel
Nabelschnurblut und so weiter es gibt
also alle möglichen Formen von von
adulten Stammzellen also Stammzellen von
ausgewachsenen Menschen die immer noch
so extrem formbare Zellen haben die sind
da nicht mehr um die potent kann man
nicht alles mitmachen aber pluripotent
das heißt kann man ziemlich viel
mitmachen in diesem Moment wo du das
machst ist die Gefahr dass der dein
Körper das abstößt gering
aber wenn es jetzt tatsächlich
Fremdgewebe ist und sei das auch
Neuschnee Fremdgewebe was du
manipulierst dann ist die Gefahr das ist
nicht angenommen wird höher und wenn man
jetzt mal die Bilanz zieht von Mitte der
90er bis heute und guckt wo hat die
medizinische Forschung mehr Durchbrüche
gemacht und mir erreicht dann liegt es
eigentlich im Bereich der adulten
Stammzellen und nicht im Bereich der im
regionalen Stammzellen und von da aus
kann man sich die Frage sollen wir das
tun müssen wir das tun müssen wir diese
Grenzen überschreiten natürlich anders
stellen als wenn das jetzt ein
eisbergwaffe wäre von dem wir uns den
ganz großen Segen für die Menschheit
versprechen können
aber es ist natürlich trotzdem
interessant ne also was was Forschung
dann am Ende auch ist also sozusagen
wertfrei urteilsfrei aber trotzdem
klingt unfassbar gruselig du gehst hin
und initiiert sozusagen
ja menschliche DNA in Affen DNA ja du du
verschmelst das sozusagen miteinander
und am Ende führt es aber dann dazu dass
du möglicherweise Organe für
Transplantation quasi züchten kannst
führt ganz genau zur Forschung rund um
diese adulten Stammzellen über die du
gerade gesprochen hast das heißt
plötzlich gibt es eine eine eine
Kehrtwende absolut
positive oder gute Richtung aber weißt
du wir haben doch gerade über die
Patente gesprochen ich habe mich immer
gefragt warum ist die Lobby hinter der
Forschung mit embryonalen Stammzellen so
laut das war ein riesen Thema
ist damals Wolfgang Kleemann damals
nordrhein-westfälischer
Ministerpräsident ist nach Israel
gereist ja um sich das alles anzugucken
und wollte solche Forschung nach
Nordrhein-Westfalen holen und der
Bundestag hat sich immer wahnsinnig
schwer getan wie regeln wir das was
machen wir da Schröder hat gesagt muss
jeder seine gewissen Entscheidung machen
hat aus diesem Grund übrigens den
Nationalen Ethikrat gegründet mit den so
bestückt dass er dann positiveres Signal
für embryonale Stammzellforschung bei
kriegt als die und cat-kommission recht
unetik der modernen Medizin die vorher
beraten da tätig war
und wenn ich mir das jetzt alles angucke
nach so einer langen Zeit und immer
denke ja aber warum denn embryonal wenn
das mit dem adulten doch eigentlich
unterm Strich viel größerer
Erfolgsgeschichte ist dann liegt es an
den Patenten
1997 wurde ein ganz folgenschwerer
Dammbruch hat kaum einer mitgekriegt
gegangen das war das damalige Novartis
Urteil und da wurde zum ersten Mal ein
Patent auf Leben vergeben das da
gentechnisch manipulierte Pflanzen und
die Pflanze kann man nicht patentieren
aber das Verfahren mit der die Pflanze
gentechnisch manipuliert ist das kann
man patentieren und wenn man sich die
Verfahren patentieren lassen kann also
das Verfahren zum Beispiel patentieren
lassen könnte mit denen ich hier mit
Schimpansen da und das Gewebe und die
Injizierung und sowas alles machen und
da irgendwie was besonderes ausgedacht
habe dann winkt dahinter ein
Milliardengeschäft und das geht mit
dadurch
ich kann das Verfahren was wenn du aus
deinen Milchzähnen aus Milchzähnen oder
aus seinem Zahnschmerzen
gewinnst und so weiter da ist nicht viel
mit patentieren patentieren aber bei
embryonalen Stammzellen ist sozusagen
der Rechtsraum man etwas anderes und das
scheint mir ein Hauptargument dafür zu
sein warum die Lobby da so stark ist das
interessant das kann ich natürlich jetzt
nicht im festen beweisen
am Ende geht es dann auch immer um Geld
und willst du abschließend gesagt sagen
Richard also kam jetzt über die die
Atombombe und die ethischen Fragen wie
es darum gab kommen sozusagen direkt ins
21 Jahrhundert und noch mal zur zur
Frage der KI palantia ja die Firma die
wir vorhin auch gerade gesprochen haben
von von Peter Thiel im
vertrauenserwecken den Peter Thiel ja
alle die mir schon ein paar mal
gesprochen haben ja genau aber auf der
anderen Seite muss man sagen diese
pallant hier äh Technik nee
im auch militärischen Bereich in Polizei
z.B auch die Polizei in Bayern demnächst
die Polizei in NRW nutzt es bereits
Polizei waren demnächst die Frage
sozusagen kannst du mit Hilfe von KI ein
Verbrechen
verhindern bevor es überhaupt passiert
nein das ist ja sozusagen die Frage um
die es geht und das ist ja militärischen
auch nichts anderes und wenn wenn die
Faustregel sozusagen geht Militärs vor
allen Dingen Logistik ja wer die
Logistik die militärische Logistik die
kriegslogistik am besten beherrscht der
wird am Ende einen Krieg gewinnen
und wenn man weiß dass heutzutage
moderne
Logistik komplett über KI läuft und KI
kann das viel viel besser als es
Menschen jemals könnten und wenn du dir
zum Beispiel Katastrophenszenarien
vorstellst ja also das ist irgendwo ein
Hurricane und dann kannst du mit Hilfe
von KI mit Satellitenaufnahmen und so
weiter kannst du sehen okay welche
Straßen sind denn eigentlich noch offen
wie können wir welche Materialien wohin
transportieren was wird wo gebraucht was
ist knapp wie können wir Lieferketten
organisieren um Menschen schnell Hilfe
zu kommen zu lassen da merkst du
plötzlich auch das ist palantierte
Technik z.B das ist an vielen Stellen
unheimlich sinnvoll würdest du sagen wir
brauchen so einen ein Moratorium wir
müssen trotzdem einmal innehalten und
meinen Schritt zurückgehen und überlegen
und sagen was sind wir bereit zu tun wo
sind die ethisch moralischen Grenzen und
was ist okay was ist erlaubt ich glaube
nicht anders moderatorium weil ich
glaube dass die meisten sich nicht dran
halten
und ich glaube nicht an das Moratorium
weil du sagst immer wir
nichts zu entscheiden weißt du also wenn
wir jetzt ein halbes Jahr lang ja also
in Deutschland zum Beispiel hingehen
würden und sagen wir wir die
KI-Forschung die irgendetwas sensibles
berührt ja ähm sei es hier militärische
KI-Forschung oder sei es eben
Möglichkeiten mit dem private Firmen in
den all Besitz von Daten kommen die sie
nicht haben sollten und so und jetzt
machen wir mal ein halbes Jahr gar
nichts die würden ihren Vogel zeigen und
wir sagen wir verlieren ein wahnsinnig
wichtiges halbes Jahr im Bett Kampf und
im Bett laufen und so weiter also das
ist völlig unrealistisch das wird nicht
stattfinden dass wir brauchen sind ganz
klare Regeln die so in diese Richtung
gehen dass künstliche Intelligenz nicht
über menschliche Schicksale entscheiden
darf das ist ein allgemeinersatz der
muss juristisch ganz ganz fein und klein
gearbeitet werden und wenn man sich
darauf verständigt und wenn man das
europaweit durchsetzt und mit Ausnahme
der militärischen Forschung geht es ja
bereits in diese Richtung dann werden
wir vielleicht die militärische
Forschung da rein bekäme wäre das schon
großartig aber ich gebe mir keiner
Illusion hin solange nicht nur der
Ukraine Krieg andauert sondern solange
die wir wieder in einen neuen Kalten
Krieg reinkommen und es wieder zu einem
Wettrüsten kommt und genau das passiert
ja gerade ja kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das eine realistische
Chance darauf hat verwirklicht zu werden
also auch das ist eine der der vielen
furchtbaren Folgen dieses dreckigen
ekelhaften schrecklichen brutalen
Angriffskrieges dass wir auch hier eine
eine menschheitsdimension der Hoffnung
verloren haben die darin besteht dass
wir nicht noch immer schlimmere Mörder
Waffen entwickeln sondern genau im
Gegenteil das wird jetzt wieder befeuert
wie nichts und und es entstehen daraus
große ethische Fragen ist übrigens auch
alles nicht neu ne also die die die das
militärische Argument lautet ja immer KI
sozusagen wie ein riesiger Lichtschalter
wir machen noch viel mehr Licht als wir
sonst irgendwie wieder in dieses Dunkel
an der Front und wo auch immer bringen
können oder wenn es darum geht
irgendwelche in welcher Bösewichte
habhaft zu werden wir machen riesigen
Lichtschalter an und sehen sehr viel
genauer was zu tun ist und ist natürlich
in Wahrheit ein sehr zwiespältiges
Argument was ich änderst du dich im Juli
88 wurde an iranischer Airbus
abgeschossen 290 Menschen sind dabei
gestorben unschuldige Leute die da drin
saßen auf dem Weg nach irgendwohin und
das war ausgelöst genau durch so einen
automatisches System also ein
us-kriegsschiff hat oder meinte er kann
zu haben die die Software da ist ein
Kampfjet unterwegs und eingedrungen
sozusagen in in den Luftraum und schießt
das Ding einfach ab kein Mensch gibt den
Befehl für diesen Abschluss keiner
steckt dahinter sondern das passiert
einfach weil die Maschine es in dem Fall
entscheidet und falsch entscheiden das
schöne wäre es dann fahren keiner ist
verantwortlich genau keiner weil jeder
wird sagen ja Moment also der der die
Maschine programmiert hat ist der
verantwortlich musste jetzt
lebenslänglich hinter Gittern oder von
internationales Gericht ja oder oder
derjenige der gerade zufällig anwesend
war während die Maschine diese Entscheid
gefällt hat
das große Problem bei künstlicher
Intelligenz ist eben die nach das
nachvollziehen oder nachverfolgen des
juristische nachverfolgen von
verantwortungsketten und das macht den
Einsatz von künstlicher Intelligenz als
Militärgerät unglaublich gefährlich ja
weil wenn ich weiß dass am Ende sowieso
keiner verantwortlich ist dann delegiere
ich das auch an die künstliche
Intelligenz ist keiner Schuld egal was
angerichtet wird keiner ist schuld wenn
eine KI dem Befehl gegeben hätte die
Atombombe abzuwerfen wer keiner Schuld
gewesen aber es werden genauso viele
Menschen gestorben aber es wäre ein
leichter gefallen das zu tun man
brauchte keinen Truman der diese
Entscheidung am Ende gefällt hat als
hätte eine Maschine ausgerechnet dass es
unter alle
Aspekte berücksichtigen dem Interesse
der USA das Beste ist das zu tun das
macht mir schon Angst das ist eine sehr
gefährliche Empfindung wer ist und in
dem zusammen auch keine gute Nachricht
an zum Schluss noch ein internationales
Abkommen gegen KI gesteuerte Waffen ist
vor drei Jahren am Widerstand und
Amerika Russland Indien und Israel
gescheitert auch Deutschland ist daran
beteiligt auch wir liefern
Software
ein wir haben es gibt ein großes
Rüstungsprojekt zusammen mit Frankreich
im Bezug auf Luftabwehr und ähnlichen
und so also es ist nicht so als wenn wir
da völlig außen vor werden also die Welt
wird nicht friedlicher das ist die nicht
gute Nachricht für heute Richard ich
dank dieser ich danke dir auch mal auf
bald also auf bald ciao
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und
Popstars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]